>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hirad Dinavari: I want
to apologize a little bit
because of the little
chaotic nature.
Sometimes we've got technical
issues, and it's out of our control.
Usually we have two screens but for
some reason today we were not able
to get two screens hooked up.
So feel cozy.
Get closer.
Move closer if you'd like to.
There's only one screen.
This is a high-tech presentation
which means there's a lot
of audio and video involved.
And so you probably don't want
to miss any of the video clips.
So I want to extend welcome
to everyone who bothered
to make time on, during the
week, during lunch hour.
I know that it's difficult
to get to the library,
and it's not the easiest
thing to get here.
And what a turn out.
Fantastic!
And on behalf of Mary Jane
[inaudible] and Joan Weeks,
the head of the Near East,
I want to welcome you.
Unfortunately, both of
them are away, not here.
This is the African and
Middle Eastern division.
We have three sections
here: the Hebraic Section,
which focuses on Judaica and
Hebrew and all materials that have
to do with Semitic languages.
The Near East Section, which focuses
on all the Arab world countries,
Arabic language around the
world, and Iranic languages from,
of course, Persian, Pashto, Kurdish,
and other Iranian languages as well
as Turkic languages, all the way
from Central Asia and Western China
to the Caucuses, as well as the
Caucasian peoples, the Armenians,
the Georgians, and
other Caucuses peoples.
It's a big division.
We represent over 80
something countries.
And of course we have the African
Section here, also as well.
Which deals with Sub-Saharan Africa.
It's a huge division.
I'm hoping this will inspire
you to come visit us and take
in other collections
that we have to offer.
Without taking too much time, I
want to say that this a continuation
of our Persian Book Lecture
Series, something that we started
with the University of
Maryland, with Fatemeh Keshavarz,
essentially The Roshan
Institute for Persian Studies,
and it's an ongoing partnership
that's been very fruitful,
that's been very rewarding.
And we've had a number of
very interesting lectures
that are fully filmed,
just like this program is.
And the good thing is once
they're filmed, they're put online
and will be there forever for people
to use, for students to look at,
for teachers to utilize, and I
see it as an electronic resource.
So without taking too
much time, I really would
like to give Fatemeh Keshavarz
an opportunity to come up here
and say a word or two about Roshan,
and introduce our lovely speaker,
Ida Meftahi, who is giving us a
lecture on gender and dance in Iran.
Again, thank you very
much for joining us.
Fatemeh Keshavarz,
[foreign language].
[ Applause ]
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz:
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome, everybody.
I can see there are classes
coming in with Dr. Akbari, so I'm,
I'm delighted that they'll be
here in time for the lecture.
Yes, indeed, this is a,
this is a great turnout.
And we're really grateful
for everyone making the time
in the middle of the day to come.
As Hirad pointed out, we have
had a very fruitful collaboration
which started, and actually,
it started before I was here
with my colleague, Dr. Ahmad
Karimi-Hakkak, here with us today.
[ Applause ]
Yes, so there were other things
happening before I was here,
but we did work on it.
We, we added.
We had a major exhibit which was
visited by about a million people.
And then we had speaker series,
and now we're continuing,
and we hopefully, I
mean it's turning
into a tradition that's
clearly worth continuing.
Roshan Institute, as you all
know, is dedicated to the study
of Persian culture,
language, and literature.
And so our collaboration
with the Library
of Congress is very, very natural.
But it has been tremendously
rewarding.
And I cannot thank
enough Hirad and Mary Jane
and all their colleagues here.
Let me just quickly say a couple
words about Dr. Ida Meftahi,
our illustrious speaker today.
Ida's been with us for
the past three years.
We hope it will be
many, many more years
as Visiting Assistant Professor
of History and Persian Studies.
She has been basically
teaching Modern Iran
and has created a really, really
a sensation among the students.
I realize that word has
negative connotations,
but in a very positive sense, people
want to learn about present-day Iran
and that's because she's been
connecting them with the culture.
The visual culture as
well as entertainment.
As well as basically everyday life.
Ida did help [inaudible]
University of Toronto
with Professor Mohammad Tavakoli,
himself a very original mind,
a very wonderful scholar
of modern Iran.
I'm sure many of you are
familiar with his work.
And Ida worked on gender and dance,
but it was really a much more
complex study of political economy
of Iran and the way
the economy of politics
and performance could
give us a special window
into understanding the
version of modernity
that Iranians crafted
for themselves.
So without further ado,
please welcome Dr. Ida Meftahi
for this presentation today.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: I also want to
say that this is a book signing,
so we have copies of the
book that she's worked
so diligently on in the back.
At the end of the program, feel free
to stop by the gentleman in the back
over there from our bookstore who
is selling copies of her book.
Thank you, again, Ida,
[foreign language].
>> Ida Meftahi: Thank
you very much, Hirad,
Dr. Keshavarz, for
your introduction.
And for facilitating this event.
Greetings, everyone, and thank you
very much for being here today.
It's truly a pleasure to be
speaking about my first book
at this remarkable place.
And for such a wonderful audience.
As in the case of many first books,
or [inaudible] dissertations
revising to first book,
Gender and Dance in Modern Iran
has a personal story behind it.
Mine starts with I was 12
when my mother first
took me to a dance class.
She hoped that dancing would
cure my extreme shyness.
This is quite a universal story for
many performers around the world,
but perhaps not a very imaginable
one for an accented Iranian woman
who has spent most of her life
in post-revolutionary Iran.
A place not always imagined as
a dance-cultivating environment.
In fact, it's largely
believed that all forms
of dance are prohibited in Iran.
My first teacher, teachers,
they were elderly Armenian women
who taught me a variety of
dances including Caucasian,
[inaudible] Persian, as well as paso
doble, tango, cha-cha, and waltz,
a peculiar repertoire
for a teenager.
When Iraq was bombing Iran,
I was rehearsing dance.
These classes inspired me and
really didn't cure my shyness.
I still struggle with it to
this day, but I had to stop them
for a while to concentrate,
concentrate on preparing
for university exams.
A few days after the
university exams,
my caring mother took me
to a second dance class.
This time with the former
soloist of National,
of Iran's Pre-Revolutionary
State Dance Company,
and one of the strongest and most
inspiring and passionate women
of my country, and a
true dance goddess.
Taught in private in settings,
her classes are for women only.
Within a few years, my teacher
came up with a particular style
of choreography for me that suited
my relatively depressed character.
And I became hooked
on into this style.
I dedicatedly spent hours every day
rehearsing dance while also being a
university student in a
drastically different world.
By late 1990s, the environment
was gradually opening up.
And we got several opportunities
to perform at women-only concerts
in front of a few hundred audiences.
And as you can see in these
images, we were quite well organized
and well dressed for the situation.
And in one of the pictures,
you can see her,
the way she has been
received by all these flowers.
In all her events, still to this
day she receives so many flowers!
In the meantime, after
several years of practice,
I had developed many questions
about the history of dance in Iran,
especially the one we
practiced, the [foreign language],
known as Iranian National Dance.
As neither the genre title,
nor the little information
that I was given was
convincing, I began dreaming
of pursing scholarly
research on dance
if I was ever given the chance.
I dreamed of writing a
book about Iranian dance.
I left Iran for Canada in 2000,
with my very supportive husband,
who is sitting in the audience.
And by 2003, I had found my
way to the Master's Program
in Dance Studies at York
University in Toronto.
Under the supervision of
Canada's leading dance historian,
Dr. Selma Odom, I graduated
with a historical thesis titled,
An Examination of Writings on
Dance in Iran from 1930 to 1980,
in which I examined numerous
periodicals with the hope
of connecting scattered
informations.
Immediately after this degree, I
started the Ph.D. at the University
of Toronto, and as Dr. Keshavarz
mentioned, I was lucky enough
to have Dr. Tavakoli
as my supervisor.
As I became increasingly
absorbed in my archival
and [inaudible] research,
my dance colleagues
in Iran became further involved
in a rapidly growing public
post-revolutionary movement based
on [inaudible] known
as [foreign language].
As I discussed in chapters seven
and eight of my book, this new genre
which emerged from the
theatrical scene only a few years
after the revolution was
indeed genealogically related
to the National Dance genre,
but of course with modifications
in the title, dance movements,
and appearance of the dancers.
Then in 2000, its founders, all
from the revolutionary-dissolved
state dance companies,
pushed forth [inaudible]
performances.
With these negotiations between
resilient performers and a difficult
and yet mutable regulations of
the Islamized theatrical stage,
the genre provided the opportunity
for underground, underground dancers
to perform publicly and
get paid for their work.
I was amazed by these new
developments, and to be honest,
as a dance practitioner in
Canada, sometimes I envied them.
It was easier to dance with
limitations than be the subject
of stereotypes about Middle
Eastern women on daily basis.
Yes, I'm from Iran, and
no, I'm not a belly dancer.
This was the phrase I
repeated numerous times
in every introductory situation.
After years of practice, I
finally admitted my defeat
to Canada's multicultural
artistic scene and gave up dancing.
Instead, I dedicated all my time
and energy to pursuing my research,
which by itself was
quite challenging.
In the absence of scholarly sources
on this topic, I had to rely mainly
on analysis of primary sources,
including the discourse on dance
in periodicals with various
ideological inclinations,
including Nationalist, Marxist, and
Islamic, interviews with artists,
performance [inaudible], audiovisual
sources including video footage
of dance and cinematic productions,
and archival documents
of official nature.
Connecting the sociopolitical
discourse on dance, music, theaters,
cinema and popular culture with
this stage dancing body as well
as the economic and regulatory
conditions that govern the stage.
I had to come up with a
historical narrative about Iran,
the dancing body, to trace
the ways it was shaped
and transformed throughout
the century.
This narrative, I argue, also
reflects the corporeal history
of urban Iranian women, of
course, in the modern era.
Conducting archival work in Iran
had its own difficulties as the term
"raghs" or dance was not commonly
used in the official settings.
So I needed to improvise and
find ways to convey it when I was
in a library or an archive.
Which sometimes resulted
in humorous situations.
Despite these challenges, I have to
confess that I met many people open
to the idea of my research
in Iran than let's say some
of our Middle Eastern Studies
colleagues outside Iran.
By 2010, I knew that one genre
on perhaps one cultural category
was missing from my research.
This was the genre that as a
performer I was supposed not
to get too close to
as the cabaret dancer.
Sorry, was -- and that was the
pre-revolutionary cabaret dancing.
This was the genre that as a
performer I was supposed not
to get close to, as the cabaret
dancer represented the other,
the vulgar, and the sexualized.
Stating that it's simply not the
high art genre of national dance
and invented 20th century
the choreographic genre
which I actually explore in
my, in chapter two of my book,
traced its trajectory to a glorious
past as far as ancient Iran.
I had learned to block out the
cabaret dancer uninhibitedly.
Aesthetically and morally, I
assumed that she wasn't worthy
of serious scholarly
examination, but on the other hand,
how could I ignore her when
she was the most dominant
and visible character
of 20th century Iran?
Dance character of
20th century Iran?
She was present in
periodicals, novels,
and pre-revolutionary
commercial cinema, but was always
as a morally dubious character.
I finally decided to tackle this
topic, and I have to be honest,
my advisor also pushed
me to do that.
But was always, and I
have to confess again
that I believe this topic became
the most important contribution
of my research.
Just to give you an idea of how
the cabaret dancer was depicted
in films prior to the revolution, I
would like you to watch the trailer
of the 1970 film, The City's
Dancer, Raqqasah'i Shahr.
While watching, please pay attention
to the leading female
role, [inaudible].
And hopefully --
[ Video Inaudible ]
Perhaps many of you are familiar
with such stereotypical
portrayal of [inaudible].
But who was she really?
And as a researcher, how could I
answer this question three decades
after the demise of cabaret dance
as a consequence of the revolution
when every available
evidence was against her?
In summer of 2011,
after a year of search,
a miracle interview
changed the situation.
When to a theater actor,
I was introduced to a lady
who I was told used to
be a cabaret dancer.
It was rare to find someone to
admit this occupation in Iran.
During our several hours of
interview, which led to another one,
so defied all the stereotypes of
a cabaret dancer as she proved
to be a multifaceted performer.
She repeatedly expressed her
grief for the gradual demise
of the former theater
district of Iran, Lalehzar.
Which she described as, quote, "the
most, the mother of Iranian theater,
all great actors of
Iran have been trained
and have performed in Lalehzar.
We were taught by our masters
to respect the theater's stage
as stage is a school for
the audiences," end-quote.
There are a section of the stage as
a school of morality was familiar
to me as it was a common notion
in the Nationalists Performing Art
discourse of 20th century Iran.
But it was unclear as to how
an actress, who was brought
up to perceive the stage as a
school of morality became involved
in cabaret dancing, an occupation
that for decades has symbolized
immoralities and social corruption
under the [inaudible] state.
After spending several years
examining historical accounts
on theater and cinema,
watching dozens of films
and having more conversations
with a few more, other performers,
I found an answer to this question.
Here I would like to briefly
show some of these findings.
The cabaret dancer, whom
I hear sometimes referred
to as [inaudible] was
associated with and participated
in multiple [inaudible],
particularly in Tehran,
namely the traditional
minstrel [inaudible],
and traditional here is kind
of under question for me.
The [inaudible] theatrical scene
of post-1950s pre-revolutionary
commercial cinema as well
as the prostitution realm.
While different in nature, it's
important to note and in ending --
that in the construction and
[inaudible] of urban culture
in 20th century, all
of these spheres fall
into the categories of low.
For instance, when they
categorize, when cultural,
in the cultural categories
of high versus low,
[inaudible] versus degenerate,
modern versus unmodern
or traditional.
All of these fell into the second
category and were considered
to be low, unmodern,
and signifies of vice
and degeneration [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
Perhaps the most important
arena which prior
to the 20th century involved
dance in Iran was the
"mutrib" or the minstrel scene.
The 20th century multifaceted
performance troops
which featured the female
[inaudible] as a member,
combined music, dance, acting, and
comedy and their hire to perform
in various public and
private functions.
After the unveiling of 1937, mutribs
also recruited women to perform
with them as actors and dancers,
replacing the transvestites
and [inaudible] of
the [inaudible] era,
we can see this cross-dressed
dancer standing
in this [inaudible]
era mutribi troupe.
This added to the stigma
that they had inherited
from their predecessors
as illiterate,
dissolute alcoholic
and drug addicts.
Nevertheless, it was natural
for those women who were born
in mutribi families and for mutribs'
spouses to become performers,
as it was a familially-constituted
occupation.
[ Inaudible ]
[Inaudible] also joined the Lalehzar
theatrical scene after 1950,
an era recognized to most
committed theater historians
as the demise of Lalehzar.
In fact, it's her presence
that signifies the demise
in most historical narratives.
As I discussed in chapter three of
my book, this so-called demise came
after a golden age of
freedom political expression.
Largely recognized
by theater activities
of the leftist theatrical
figure of the [inaudible].
If your familiar is
mostly known as the father
of modern Iranian theater, but
also he was a core member of,
to the party.
[ Inaudible ]
This side of a golden age of theater
in Iran was ascribed to the era
between the abdication of
[inaudible] and the coup.
Even before this golden age, the
Lalehzar district had a reputation
for cosmopolitan artistic
experimentation with the ideas
of modernity and nationhood.
For a number of reasons,
which I discuss in my book,
after 1950 the private sector
of Lalehzar theater both status
as a center for high-art cultural
production and its typical elite
or middle class audience.
In this time of economic hardship,
the manager of Tehran Theater,
which was the largest theater at the
time, located at Lalehzar Street,
hired some foreign
dancers to perform
in segments called
atraksiun or attraction.
Following him, other
theater owners hired dancers,
and atraksiun became prevalent
and later took over Lalehzar.
While economically, dancers
helped the financial shortcomings,
the idea of naked dancers in
Lalehzar raised new moral issues
and reactions from the
artistic community.
Subsequently, the government
bans performances
by foreign dances in
Lalehzar in 1957.
Instead, the Iranian [inaudible]
and her mutrib colleagues
dominated the atraksiun scene.
As dancing paid better than
acting, way better in fact,
some Lalehzar actresses including my
above-mentioned interviewees joined
the atraksiun scene.
The main arena of activity
for raqqas however was Tehran's
nightlife which had been expanding
since 1940s when a number of cafes
and cabarets opened in various parts
of Tehran, including
the Lalehzar district.
As I discuss in chapter four of
my book, why the term [inaudible]
and [inaudible], terms
[inaudible] appeared together,
these spaces differed greatly in
terms of the quality of performance
and the price of food
and alcohol as well
as the class of their [inaudible].
When Tehran's nightlife
was expanding in the 1950s,
two groups of women were competing
for this newly-created occupation,
foreign dancers who performed
at hotels and theaters,
and those Iranian women who dared
to set foot on stage to perform
in the locus of everyone's
attention.
Perhaps some of these
women, including those
from the mutribi troupes or those
who were [inaudible]
theater practitioners had a
performance background.
But the majority of the early
cabaret dancers had no expertise
other than their home-based,
familial-setting solo improvised
dance or [foreign language]
that Iranians do in parties.
So these new performers had to
train themselves in a variety
of trendy genres including
Indian, Arabic, Spanish,
and even American dance
while watching films
as well as each other.
So I'm just going to show you
some video clips of these dancers,
and I assume that this
is American dance.
[ Inaudible Video ]
Under the guise of elaborate
stage names such as [inaudible],
and Princess, the dancers
traveled from one venue to another
and presented themselves, their
act, and their dance styles,
according to the venues' regulations
and the audiences' expectations.
As the dancers age,
beauty, on-stage behavior,
and outfit also contributed to their
reception, they were subjugated
by their employers'
to some disciplinary corporeal
criteria including obligatory
revealing clothing.
Some employers also
enforced off-stage activities
on their performances, performers
by selling their customers to try
to drink with the dancers,
the custom that was
called [foreign language].
This also could imply
that the dancer had agreed
to an official contract
that required her to meet
with the male customer outside
of the performance venue.
While the official law
strictly prohibited these venues
from facilitating or
providing any means for immoral
or unchaste sexual activities
and from hiring or giving wages
to people for this purpose,
the government enforced
atraksiun performers
to take compulsory medical exams
every six months to make sure
that the performers, they're not
transmitters of sexual diseases
in case they engaged in sexual
acts with the audiences.
Such [inaudible] government's
dual attitude is clarified
in the city police or [inaudible]
classification of prostitution
that recognized all female
servants of Tehran's nightlife
as prostitutes, thus placing
the cafes and cabarets
in a [inaudible] position between
performance sphere and covert,
and covert prostitution sites.
This all-encompassing
and deterministic attitude is also
observable in the press discourse
of the [inaudible] that a
cabaret dancer's past, present
or future is strongly
associated with prostitution.
Appearing in various forms
of writing including reports
and fictions, male journalists,
journalists sold their papers
featuring the desired image
of the prostitute raqqas.
While simultaneously
condemning or ridiculing her.
Tehran's nightlife was
also publicized as a space
for forgetting the day-to-day,
day-to-day mechanicalistic,
modern life where audience
members supposedly delved
into their own fantasies
by watching performances.
But if the nightlife was a space
for forgetting and fantasizing,
the pre-revolutionary Iranian
cinema definitely was a space
to watch the fantasy unfold.
As I explain in chapter five of
my book, Iranian cinema made use
of dancing bodies from its
early days, even from 1930s,
but it was the cabaret raqqas
who dominated the screen.
And who supposedly seductive
dancing body also made,
made up for the lack of sex scenes.
And teased the sexual
imagination of the audiences.
Beginning with the production of
the 1949 film, [foreign language],
kafahs and cabarets became the space
which came to represent the audible,
ultimate urban vice onscreen as
Iranian cinema deployed the pleasure
of watching the dissolute
while condemning it as immoral.
The performers and the audience
of cabarets were all part
of this attractive
spectacle of vice.
By 1954, the [inaudible] was
already exhausted so much
that film critics started
complaining that most films produced
to that date featured
cabaret scenes.
The improper insertions of song
and dance segments, they claim,
damage the storyline
that had to be paused
when the on-screen café spectators
and the cinema audiences
all gazes at dancing bodies.
In the cinema discourse, the
dancing body was largely associated
with eroticism or shahvat,
a nakedness, [inaudible],
which were perceived as
selling factors in films.
Yet as dance segments
guaranteed the box office sale,
they were not only inserted
into Iranian productions,
but also into cowboy films
when they were shown in Iran.
Even though dancings were regularly
features in films in the 1950s
and '60s, there are [inaudible]
appeared as a character.
It's only in the late
1960s, and especially
after the aforementioned 1970
film which we watched a trailer,
its trailer, Raqqasah'i Shahr, that
the dancer became a lead character.
After the success of this tactic,
several films with the term
"Raqqasah" in the title or Raqqasah
as a leading character,
were produced.
[ Inaudible ]
The myths surrounding her cotillion
life was persistently present.
Some films depicted her
as a part-time prostitute.
Others portrayed her as a
self-sacrificing single mother,
but most more often in the
films she was in love with a man
for whom she is ready to change.
The resolution of her journey most
often involves leaving the public
stage of the cabaret by agreeing to
marry a male hero, and retreating
to the private, moral
realm of the home.
When she swears to forget her dark
past and become his ideal housewife.
But no matter what, her
past always haunts her.
In the Iranian movies, the dancer's
life story may have unfolded
in different ways, but it
always reproduced the myths
of her off-stage life, something
that was locally produced in Iran.
Disciplined by the director
and framed by his lens,
raqqas' supposedly out of control
body, attire, movements, and mimicry
and comedy were striking,
elating, and recognizable.
Her audience not only
enjoyed her attractiveness,
but also took pleasure in
understanding and recognizing her
and blaming her at the same time.
In the fantasy of films, her
male audiences could identify,
could identify with the onscreen
cabaret audience and the movie hero,
the one who rescued this femme
fatale by possessing her.
If she didn't obey,
she would be slapped
and called a prostitute
in a harsh way.
In the final years of the
[inaudible] there was a backlash
from the cinema community
and the more powerful female casts
including [inaudible] who appeared
in the film that you watched.
Who resented the way in which their
bodies had been treated onscreen.
Some actresses left
their job forever,
as they couldn't tolerate
the pressures imposed
on their bodies in performance.
Nevertheless, new faces
are replacing them
to keep the private sector
entertainment industry
of the [inaudible] running, an
industry which in the absence
of government support, was highly
dependent on the [inaudible] economy
of its dancers and actresses.
The revolutionary discourse
which I extensively explore
in my book also responded to
the abuse of the men's sexuality
and their [inaudible]
representation.
And blamed the [inaudible] state
for disseminating social corruption.
An example of this attitude
is evident in an article
that recognized sex, dance,
alcohol, and drugs as weapons
of U.S. imperialism to which the
disinherited [inaudible] countries
were held back and weakened.
It was in this context that
with the Revolution of 1979,
the public spaces of leisure
associated with prostitution
and eroticism, such
as cinemas, cabarets,
as well as the prostitution
district were banned altogether.
And this is one of
the famous cabarets,
[inaudible] which was
located on Lalehzar Street.
While some of the performing
arts were disrupted for a while,
they gradually found
their way back to stage.
Even national dance, as I mentioned
earlier, was originally [inaudible].
Nevertheless, in government's
discourse and most importantly
in the social imagination of
Iranians all around the world,
cabaret dance and its interconnected
realms including Lalehzar Street,
Lalehzar scene, continued
to constitute a negative
and suspicious space,
a contributing factor
to the challenges I faced
while writing about them.
After the submission of
my book for publication,
I initiated a new digital project
on Lalehzar Street
between 1900 and 1979.
Which I believe will shed light on
many aspects of urban, diplomatic,
and social history of modern Iran.
This, this project is part of the
Roshan Institute, Roshan Initiative
in Persian Digital Humanities.
But I know that for at
least a decade to come,
I will be receiving more
smiles and surprises
than I introduced its
title, Lalehzar.
But ladies, ladies and gentlemen,
I'm up for the challenge again.
Thank you very much for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: We have about ten
minutes for questions and answers.
And I have a request, since there
is audiences all the way back there,
when they ask something,
could you also repeat it
so that we have that [inaudible]?
>> Ida Meftahi: Sure.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Thank you very much.
Go ahead, [inaudible].
>> Questions?
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Actually,
this is not a question.
I just want to say
that Dr. Meftahi is --
has a team of people
that we have [inaudible]
at Roshan Institute collecting
materials and rare documents
from photographs to interviews to,
you know, all kinds of documents
that were contributed as [inaudible]
project which really shed light
on a very important aspect of
the development of the culture.
So she kind of -- just [inaudible]
talk, she was modest about it.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Yeah, I had a question
about you mentioned earlier
that there were foreign
dancers and Iranian dancers.
I was wondering if the
foreign dancers tended to be
from certain places or was like a
certain group of people who occupied
that role, Western style of dancing?
>> Ida Meftahi: Yes,
well there, okay,
so [inaudible] question here is
about basically the background
of the foreign dancers,
where they came from,
and what type of dances
they performed.
And I think from 1940s on, we see,
we hear about foreign dancers.
I know that, for instance,
Polish refugees performed
when they were in Iran.
They basically took refuge in Iran
in the Polish cafe
on Lalehzar Street.
Other than that, we've heard
about -- I mean there are many,
various versions of this:
German dancers, French dancers,
Arabic dancers, belly dancers.
And sometimes even people claim to
be foreign but they were Iranian
because it was more
attractive to people, so.
But later on when this whole
scene of cabaret dance grew,
they were commissioning
performers to come and perform.
For instance, Jerry Lewis was
one of the people who came and,
you know, performed in a cabaret.
So cabaret became an institution for
entertainment, basically by itself.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes.
Yes. And well, I would say
for sure some of them were,
some of the Iranian, some
of the Armenian performers were also
performing in the cabaret setting.
But most of the time you hear their
names associated with the more,
sort of the higher arts, national
art, national dance setting.
They were the, basically they
were the first women to perform
on this kind of high art setting.
And then gradually they trained more
and more Iranian women in ballet,
for instance, and open,
opened up for others.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. So my, my dance
teacher, first dance teacher,
of the Armenian couple
that I mentioned,
they were in fact,
ballet instructors.
It was Madame [inaudible], but
my serous dance training was
with [inaudible] who, as I
mentioned, was the soloist
of the National Dance Company
prior to the revolution,
who had also as a national dancer
received ballet training before.
Ballet training, basically ballet
kind of started with the immigrants,
Armenian immigrants
who came to Iran.
And yes, I mention it in my second
chapter, and their contributions
to this whole idea
of national dance,
and the National Ballet
Company of Iran.
Yes, they're very present there.
[ Inaudible ]
Even in earlier time, you see
a lot of Russian folk dances,
for instance, being
performed in 1920s and '30s.
Since [inaudible] time, we've
seen performance of folk groups
from different regions in let's say
[inaudible] and places like that.
But since 1940s, there were
attempts of staging folk dances,
but most of the time they
were stylized versions.
Of course I'm particularly
talking about,
you know, official stage in Iran.
But here and there you see them
becoming more involved and by 1960s,
there's this official group
folk dance company that was,
there's basically, their
whole occupation was
to present folk dances.
And sometimes they were
groups that were brought from,
you know, different regions.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes.
Uh, no. So the question
was about [inaudible]
or theater or was it dance?
Yes, [inaudible] theater and dance,
they are very much
associated with [inaudible].
So, I -- yes.
So I didn't show them, but
they're part of that realm.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. I mean, from what I gathered
from this, from the interviews,
with my interviewees who were also
involved with the mutribi setting,
yes, to a degree they were Jewish.
Or non-Muslim.
But at some point in
Iran, whoever wanted
to join the artistic scene
had to join the mutribs.
If they could afford, they could go
to, you know, better place maybe,
more official institution
which was being developed
from [inaudible] era.
But before that, really
if you loved to do music
and you couldn't afford a better
way, your local musician was there.
I would say they were the
preservers of Iranian culture.
Before, you know.
>> I just have one question.
>> Ida Meftahi: Yes?
>> Growing up and not an expert
on dance, I kind of saw dance
in Iran divide into
three subcategories.
One was the [inaudible],
that official stuff.
And dances like [inaudible]
which was staged
and very professionally --
>> Ida Meftahi: Yes.
>> Then there was the folk troupes,
and then there was the whole thing
[inaudible] cabaret, and sort of.
Is that a correct way to
categorize, or are there more genres
or subcategories that
I'm overlooking?
>> Ida Meftahi: Well, no.
Actually, I think, and these
are basically the three dances
characters that I've
been discussing,
except for the folk dance
that I don't get into.
It's in the context
of the, you know,
preservation the national
culture of Iran.
So in a way that folk dance, the
way they present it became part
of that national culture more than,
you know, presenting folklore life.
So yes, that, the way
they categorize dance was
[foreign language].
So national dancers
and folk dancers,
and my teacher was a
soloist of [inaudible],
and [inaudible] was presented
by the National Ballet of Iran
which was again, housed
in [inaudible].
So they were kind of
very close together.
And the third category
was [foreign language].
Cabaret dancer.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
One more question,
and then we have a book
signing, [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Ida Meftahi: I intentionally
decided to, I mean,
in my book explore just, you
know, the official stage.
But I've, I mean, even, even some
of the mutribs or [inaudible] were
by themselves kind of gypsy types
that they, you know, traveled
and then in the 20th
century, they settled.
But I've heard of gypsy
dancers in [inaudible] as well,
and I know that they have, I mean
and I've heard that they have,
you know, some kind of similarities
to gypsy dances in Iraq.
So they're probably, you know,
there are some connections.
But as I say, said, I don't
address it in my book.
[ Inaudible ]
National folk, the [inaudible]
dancers of Iran which, as I,
as I mentioned, my advisor
was, my teacher was a soloist,
they did stage [inaudible]
gypsy dance.
But I would say it
was very stylized.
[ Inaudible ]
Actually, in the pre-revolutionary
Iranian cinema, when they wanted
to show, you know, dancers this
style of dance of but not getting
to the whole, you know, problems,
complications of cabaret dance.
They were like using gypsy
dancers, gypsy dance characters
who exactly reflected
the same people.
>> Hirad Dinavari: One last comment.
Thank you very much,
Ida [inaudible].
On your chairs, you have little
forms to help us and the University
of Maryland to better have,
improve our programs for you.
Please feel free to make comments.
If you want to be added
to our email list
for getting events notices,
please add your emails.
We would love to hear from you.
And we have now gone high tech.
We have a blog, Four Corners Blog.
We have an example
of it on your chair.
This will continue to showcase blogs
about the African Middle Eastern
Division, the Asian Division,
the European and Hispanic.
All the four reading
rooms that the [inaudible]
international collections.
And the, the blog on your
chair is dealing with one
of our Hebrew collections.
What do you call it?
It's a piece on one of the
Judaica material that's right now
being showcased.
So do us a favor and put a little
bit of effort into your comments,
because it really does
help us improve.
Now, let's go to the book signing,
and please feel free
to buy a book from Ida.
And meet with her over there.
She will be there to
sign if anyone purchases.
Or feel free to come up and
speak with her directly.
We need to put a official end
to this because it's now 1:00.
And researchers need to come and
start using the reading room.
Thank you very much, and thank you
very much for making time and coming
out of your busy day to this event.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.com.